الرئيس الاوكراني
ان بلاده بحاجه للاسلحه العنقوديه
الامريكيه الصنع للدفاع عن نفسها مؤكدا
حصر استخدامها فقط داخل اراضي اوكرانيا
التي تحتلها روسيا في المقابل قال الكريم
اوكرانيا بثائر عنقوديه يغير الوضع ويجبر
روسيا على اتخاذ اجراءات مضاده حسب تعبيره
وفي الاثناء قال مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جايك ان الرئيس الامريكيه سيناقش
مساله تزويد اوكرانيا بالصواريخ بعيده
المدى مع الرئيس الاوكراني والصويصله
دراسه الامر وكان وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
قد كشف انه على اتصال بالمسؤولين
الامريكيين بشان تزويد بلاده بصواريخ
اذكنز التي يصل مداها الى 300 كيلو متر
ومن ناحيه الثانيه نقلت صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز عن مسؤولين الامريكيين ان اداره
بايدن تجري نقاشا داخليا بشان الموافقه
على ارسال عدد محدود من صواريخ ارض ارض
الى اوكرانيا